[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with the
Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine and the
associate editor of the Daily Mirror Kev
Maguire welcome to both of you as ever a
look at the front pages to start with
let's kick off with the financial times
then the Ft leading on the economy
claiming there's little hope for the end
of the cost of living crisis with
inflation stuck in double digits the eye
has a similar story reading the UK faces
five percent interest rates after
failing to tame inflation while the
mirror calls it a living nightmare
the times is reporting a 19 increase
their lead that's the guardian apologies
the guardian is reporting senior
Ministry of Justice officials are ready
to quit if the Deputy Prime Minister
survives his bullying inquiry well the
Metro is focusing on the threat from
Russian hacker with the front page
reading Putin cyber Blitz on the UK The
Daily Express is leading with two rival
MPS joining together to protect women's
rights against extremist trans activists
and the Daily Star reports on the
Netflix conspiracy theorist confusing
the Earth is in fact not flat or not as
flat as we hoped
uh well a reminder by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of the papers while you watch us
so let's join our guest then Sarah Vine
and Kevin McGuire and Sarah why don't
you start with the financial times
um certainly all that optimism in in
recent months at the start of this year
that the UK wouldn't go into recession
uh that inflation would fall rapidly
from the middle of the year starting to
feel a bit sketchy Now isn't it
it is and this is really important for
Rishi he needs this is what he needs to
get under control and of course but for
most people you know
obviously the cost of living is is is
painful but also interest rates uh you
know that's the one thing that uh
everyone in the UK is terrified of is an
interest rates going up when we saw what
happened last year with uh Liz truss's
disastrous
says budget which sent them skyrocketing
and all sorts of people in Desperate
trouble really not being able to or
worried about not being able to pay
their mortgages
um so so it's so important for him to
get inflation down and uh it's just not
going the way that he had hoped
unfortunately I mean these papers are
all quite Doom and Gloom aren't they I
mean there really isn't uh much good
news
um apart from obviously the flat earther
who is quite entertaining
um it does feel like uh we'd had we've
had a little bit of a bounce and and now
it feels like we're sort of coming back
to Earth whether or not it's flat I
don't know yeah we're on the on the drop
of the Boeing I suppose is what you you
might describe it the problem seems to
be that core inflation you take out the
really wobbly bits is still high and
some of that they say is the service
sector which means wages which I guess
is what the government's warned about in
terms of wage increases in the public
sector as well
um and as your paper points out the
bigger problem is it's food you can't
avoid buying food and that's where we've
seen the big increases Kevin
no absolutely uh food's the new fuel
driving inflation 19.1 percent uh it
went up that is the highest for 45 years
and inflation was predicted expected to
go from 10.4 to 9.8 but it stubbornly
remained in double figures at 10.1
that's on the consumer prices index
retail prices indexed a bit wide out
involves housing is 13.5 but now you're
right the food and it's one of the
reasons the UK Imports a lot of food
which is why our inflation is higher
than the other major economies and the
ge7 are Japan us France Italy uh Canada
and whoever I've missed out uh Germany
uh all uh all have lower lower inflation
but it's really really hurting people
and wages are not going up anywhere near
as fast as inflation which is why people
uh I've seen the real value of wages
going there living standards being being
hammered I think the figure four or
average rises in the Public Services is
four and a half percent uh if inflation
is 10.1 you can you can see that's a big
gap that's a big difference that's a
that's a big hit and it's one of the
reasons why there are strikes and you
have the Royal College of Nursing
teaching unions rejecting
um higher offers from the government yes
and I mean there's multiple things going
on um Sarah I was just going to say that
the U.S Central Bankers played really
hard ball on their interest rates which
means the dollar is stronger our pound
is weaker problem is we import a lot of
stuff we put Goods we import food we
import energy more than the Eurozone and
more than the United States so there's
persistent reasons why our inflation
would be expected to stay high
yes I mean and as Kevin says you know
one of the one of the the things that
the government one of the sort of
carrots the government are using it if
you like to it to sort of push back on
the strikes is the idea that inflation
will come down and therefore you know
the nursing unions the BM that the
doctors don't need these very high uh
um pay uh increases that they're
demanding so it's so it sort of it it
blows a hole in in quite a lot of the
government strategy over the next six to
eight months it's very important that
they get a handle on it which is why I
suspect they will have to put these
interest rates up next week which will
be very painful for a lot of people and
of course you know the housing market is
already down I think it's 20 you know
they're they're predicting quite you
know that there are some big drops
coming and a lot of people have over the
last 20 years well maybe not 20 Sorry
probably more like 10 15 years because
we've had historical historical low
rates of Interest people have ever
borrowed they've borrowed more than they
can really afford in a sort of sensible
interest rate market so a lot of people
would have really overstretched
themselves
um to buy houses in an inflated Market
which has inflated it even more and now
this is real crunch time and and I
always think within with Britain you
know our homes are our castles and we
are a nation of homeowners that is the
dream and much more so than Europe uh
where people tend to rent much more it's
the rental market is much better again
rentals the rental market the housing
crisis people can't afford to rent house
rents have gone up in London alone at 20
it's it's really difficult
um Ordinary People to just get a roof
over their heads
um and that's oh sorry the cat and that
you know this is this is all the problem
I do I am so sorry every time I do skies
she's here she loves you
it's our voice Kevin it draws the cat in
yeah
she's in love with Kevin
it's the purring good nature
magnetism Kevin
as we just as we discuss economic
catastrophe yeah
probably worried about where his next
meals coming from I think pet food sword
yeah exactly still food even if it's for
animals um but the eye picking up on
that point about uh interest rates UK
faces a five percent interest rate rise
and the point about rents going up well
that's partly because the little
landlords are saying their mortgages go
up so they're putting rents up and
certainly the mayor of London talking
only today about you know a rent freeze
or Price controls which presumably would
make more little landlords leave the
business and sell up anyway so who knows
what the answer is to this but uh
Downing Street the paper saying faces a
fresh dilemma in the ongoing standoff
with NHS Medics overpay they presumably
be hoping by dragging it out inflation
Falls and the argument goes away is that
is that one of the reasons for the
stalling do you think
um I think that an incompetence yes I
think like the the prime minister is has
got his five goals and as Sarah
mentioned one is Harvard inflation by
the end of the year now that may still
happen there could be a pretty hefty
fall as a big uh fuel price increase
comes out of the figures next month you
know triggered by Putin's invasion of
Ukraine the office for Budget
responsible you were forecasting
inflation down at 2.9 by the uh end of
the year that may look a little
optimistic but it will come down but if
it comes down it's still prices will
still be going up it's just they're not
going up at the current double digit
rate so nobody's going to get uh any
richer because the eye picks up in uh
interest rates now 4.25 could go out to
five percent well you do that then of
course people who've got mortgages loans
credit cards are going to be hit that
way so it's a very crude method of
trying to control inflation because one
it really says it's going to take away
your spending power so you have less
when you go to the shop so then those
people in the shops will have to lower
their prices to try and get your cash
but you know the poor uh you know John's
and Jenny's of this world will will
still be hit they will be in the teeth
uh of a terrible cost of living crisis
and uh the government isn't entirely to
blame of course it isn't but it will
take a lot of the blame because it's in
power
well with an aging population we should
also be a nation of Savers I guess and
it does help savers who had years in the
doldrum so let's look at the bright side
as Sarah says we need to Renaissance but
the banks never pass on this they never
pass on the hikes they don't you don't
you just don't get you know you'd be
lucky to get you know four percent and
that's if you promise never to ever use
your money or move it or do anything
with it I mean that's the other thing I
mean I I'm not I'm old enough to
remember the last time the katori
government you know presided over
interest rate hikes you know there was
at the end of beginning of the 90s they
were up at 15 I think Kevin yeah I
remember that yeah and there are there
are and let's not forget that Tory
voters you know are those homeowners you
know Margaret Thatcher did the right to
buy thing because it appealed to Tory
voters and there are lots of people who
haven't forgiven you know who who said
that at the time they would forgive the
Tories because they were in negative
equity and um that was a very traumatic
time and and you know I don't want to
see that well it could happen again I
think yeah the the proportion of the
country that uh owned their own home are
buying their their hope is down from
2010 and of course social housing's also
taken a a big hit Council housing has
gone down so people are left up the
mercy of private landlords uh and that
is proving very very expensive this I
think this is what will come back it was
it the Elder slogan in the Clinton Ear
urgency economy stupid I think this is
what's going to do for for Rishi sooner
I can consider as well well that and the
terrible state of Public Services yeah
September uh 1990 no sorry in 1992 can't
remember the month now I remember being
in Newcastle and being sent by uh the
national news to doing Vox pops on the
15 increase on the streets of Newcastle
your neck of the words though not quite
I know don't I'm not going to say you're
from Newcastle I do know um now then
let's move on to Shield yeah there we go
got it in
so let's go to the guardian um Kevin why
don't you start uh also stalling one
might argue is the investigation into
the behavior of Dominic Robb what is the
guardian suggesting here
yeah the Deputy Prime Minister and
Justice secretary in the guardian is
saying they've been told by Whitehall
insiders that the report by Adam Tolley
King's Council KC into allegations
dozens of allegations of bullying by
Dominic Robb which he strongly denies
could be delivered to sunac tomorrow
Thursday uh and then there would be a
decision uh when to publish it it's a
it's a report based I think you get the
facts the evidence rather than reach
conclusions but once he gets it sunak is
going to have to make a decision whether
he One Believes there was bullying and
bad behavior and two if he does what
happens does he sack his deputies
already lost Gavin Williamson the
minister uh without portfolio in the in
the uh in the cabinet who was accused of
um being vile to a well he was actually
vile uh to uh then uh former Chief Whip
and then also nadeem's awari over his uh
tax Affairs that resigned as the cabinet
office Minister could he be full could
he be facing the third resignation and
if there is no resignation according to
the guardian then Senior uh civil
servants in the ministry of Justice are
going to resign so whichever way this
goes it's going to be bad for the Prime
Minister well well the guardian does
quote Rob as consistently denying any
bullying of civil servants including
some in senior roles and the mood music
amongst some Tory MP Sarah has been
politics is a hard business you know he
demanded high standards at what point
does that cross into bullying is
effectively the question they're
throwing out there
yes and I think also you know the the
question of what constitutes bullying
has changed a lot over the last even
just the last five years I mean you know
Kevin and I grew up in newspapers where
people would regularly throw things at
you and Paul you all sorts of unpleasant
names that wasn't considered bullying
that was just considered editing so you
know things have changed and and I think
when you have multi-generational
workforces
um there will be some younger people who
find what older people like Kevin and I
say and do very offensive and
inappropriate as they like to say so I
think I think that it's it's a cultural
thing and it's it's quite a difficult
it'll have to be a judgment the Prime
Minister will have to make a judgment I
mean I don't think the loss of Gavin
Williamson has been noticed unduly
um in the political spectrum and seeing
I'm not sure whether raw would leave a
gaping hole I mean the lib Debs have
been challenging for his seat for a long
time we know don't we've got an election
next year just very quickly Kevin sorry
we've got to move on yeah the waters
close over the heads of ministers who
who go very very quickly I think
workplaces are better now that bad
behavior isn't tolerated but I do recall
that Boris Johnson when he was prime
minister had a report uh by his ethics
advisor that uh accused well concluded
pretty Patel uh he was a home secretary
at the time had been a bully in several
departments she issued an apology and
wasn't uh wasn't sacked so the ethics uh
advisor resigned uh but sunak is about
to be somebody of a higher personal
caliber than Johnson so I think if wrong
if if and I say and he denies it if Rob
is accused of bullying I think it'll be
very difficult to uh to keep him okay uh
interesting days ahead anyway both of
you stay there lots more still to come
including is Britain about to be
targeted by pro-russia hackers
discussing that more after breaking
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me once again the Daily
Mail columnist Sarah Vine and the
associate editor of the Daily Mirror Kev
Maguire welcome back to both of you um
Kevin let's go to the telegraph shall we
which has the extraordinary story that
Russian spy ships are apparently mapping
wind farms and key communication cables
off the coast of Britain and elsewhere
but the plan the suggestion of the plan
is to sabotage critical infrastructure
yeah and now they have a picture of one
of the vessels with an armed uh man or
operative whatever agent whatever
whatever he is someone just uh disguised
as uh fish fishing programs sorry
fishing fishing ships and we've
similarly have the warning from all of
Oliver Dowd and the cabinet office
Minister and the head of the national
cyber security Center uh Power Health
transport that could all be targeted in
a way we shouldn't be surprised because
we are supplying tanks and missiles and
other equipment to be used against
Russia in Ukraine where we impose
sanctions on them many many individuals
and the economy so you would expect them
I'm afraid we've got to prepare for this
and defend against it you would expect
them to to be assertive of them
themselves
we are vulnerable cables are cables
Under the Sea are vulnerable well
absolutely I was just going to quote Ben
Wallace actually the defense secretary
who won't last year that Norway's oil
and gas infrastructure was particularly
vulnerable and the Royal Navy purchasing
two dedicated subsea surveillance ships
which are expected to come into service
this year the Metro picks up on the the
warning about cyber Blitz as well on the
UK you know the sense of an all-out
proxy war is is desperately frightening
uh for the West Sarah
yes I mean I agree but I don't think as
Kevin says I don't think I don't think
anyone would be surprised to think the
Russians are spying on us I mean of
course they're spying on us
um they probably never stop spying on us
and all these uh infrastructure
are very vulnerable to this sort of
thing I mean you know we've already seen
it but the Russians have already done
stuff like that
um I wonder how much of releasing this
information has got to do with the fact
that the governments are going to do
their siren warning at three o'clock on
Sunday and some people have been a
little bit critical of this I mean
there's a I get a sense
of oh you must be absolutely terrified
about everything because that way
um you know we can stop you all from
distract you all from the cost of living
crisis and the fact that you're about to
lose your homes because your interest
rates are going to go through the roof
but maybe I'm just being a cynic I don't
know
um yeah I'm not surprised that the
Russians spying on us I would expect
them to do so and as Kevin says we we're
actively helping the ukrainians so in
their eyes we're the enemy and uh
Kevin you've got 30 seconds left to do
another story I do apologize
go on oh you you finish your sentence
you're going to anyway okay so you have
a national grid for Angie but the
government has not a national a grid for
for announcements I'm sure it's uh it's
it's no coincidence on the day of bad
economic news that this is uh floated
okay interesting yes Oliver Dowden
revealing the national cyber security
Center has issued an official threat
notice uh no seconds for you to do any
story I'm going to do it very quickly
which is a fascinating demographic tale
that India is poised to outstrip China
in terms of the world's biggest
population
um 1.425 billion is what China has it's
going to be more than that by middle of
this year we've been waiting for this to
happen but it's a truly fascinating
anyway we're late I'm over Kevin McGuire
Sarah Vine thank you very much